SPEAKER: Today I'm
going to show you
how to create a table
in BigQuery with Ruby.
I'm creating a table to
track my cat pictures.
The Google Cloud BigQuery gem
is the easiest way to do this.
To use the gem you need a
project and a service account
key.
I created these earlier.
Now to create my table.
First, I require Google Cloud.
Now I'm going to create
a BigQuery object.
Groups of tables in BigQuery
are called data sets,
so I'm creating a data
set called Pictures.
Now I can create the table.
I'm naming it Cats,
and I'm passing
in the schema as a block.
This is very similar to
creating migrations in Rails,
so it should feel natural.
That's it.
Now I have a table in BigQuery.
To verify that, you can go to
the BigQuery console, reload,
and you'll see there
is my cats table.
I hope you found this helpful.